hello YouTube fan I'm Gillian Jenny oh
and I'm Evan Hall and we are producers
at great big story you know I just got
back from a particularly exciting shoot
we really want to share with you guys we
were in Devil's Tower Wyoming America's
first National Monument
it is basically this enormous rock
formation that is jutting out of the
Prairie in northeastern Wyoming we were
there to talk to Frank was Frank Frank
Sanders was the guy who we followed up
this gigantic rock go rock that stuff
cracks me up
he has been climbing that big rock since
the 70s
how you feeling Frank kickin I was ready
man I get to go climb I get to sail with
Christopher Columbus to do a video about
Frank we had to do some rock climbing
and how much experience did you and I
have rock climbing I had never Rock
climbed before the rock wants to be
climb and yeah I've been to a rock to
maybe a handful of times in a way it was
good that we'd never wrought pine before
really because we didn't really know
what we were getting into okay all right
cool and this is pretty advanced rock
climbing Julian if you had showed me a
picture of the route that we were going
to climb I would have said no way
yeah before we left on our shoot we had
a talk with our boss our boss wanted
that sunset shot at the top of the tower
and the only way to get that shot is to
climb up the rock with a camera in tow
you basically cannot have any anything
on you like no backpack nothing in your
pockets really because you're wedging
yourself into these cracks Frank had a
duffel bag basically and so we packed as
carefully as we could all of our
equipment and then the bag gets hauled
up as you go there were a lot of times
when I thought this is not possible when
we got to the top of the tower I was
four so proud of us
and also relieved that I could bring
back this footage to my boss and be like
you asked for it we got it it took us
eight hours to get to the top of the
tower and it took us four hours to
rappel down normally when we do issues
of video we're trying to create is the
number one priority you know as it
probably should be but in this case the
personal journey was just so big and so
difficult that's what I loved about this
shoot is that it transcended what we
were doing it was no longer about
getting the shot for our boss it was
about doing this for ourselves and
getting to the top because we just
wanted to in the end so if you like this
new experimental behind-the-scenes thing
that we're doing let us know leave a
comment yeah and if you want to actually
watch the story that we're talking about
then just click here we're here right
here somewhere around here somewhere
around us there will be a link to the
devil's power story and we hope you guys
enjoy it
well alright I'm sorry